I've been trying to tell you I can't
convey through words the real urgency
that I feel the midterms uh and what it
means for the country in five days
anyway here now with reaction South
Carolina Senator our friend Tim Scott
he's done a phenomenal job he's traveled
all over the country on behalf of
Republican candidates everywhere great
to have you back Senator thank you here
we are five years to go closing
arguments Democrats are desperate they
say all Republicans want to cut Social
Security Medicare VA benefits it's all
LIE there's not one person that's
advocating that and they seem desperate
I smell desperation in the air Sean
you're 100 right what you said during
the monologue is so important it's
Crystal Clear if we are to win the
majority in the Senate it takes every
single voter in a Battleground State who
is sick and tired of being sick and
tired Republicans Democrats and
independents to show up and vote for the
Republican candidate remember this Sean
in the state of Georgia January 5th 2021
the loss of a single senate seat cost
the American taxpayers more than 4
trillion dollars one seat that seat
could be held tomorrow as we get through
this election by General Don Bolduc a
true American Patriot winning in New
Hampshire might be the state that takes
us across and gives us a majority in
Georgia North Carolina Ohio Wisconsin we
have to win Nevada Arizona every single
voter hear me clearly your vote matters
today more than it has ever mattered we
must finish this race don't run to the
Finish Line run through the Finish Line
there is too much at stake I understand
you don't have the American dream
Pennsylvania yeah
Washington Tiffany Smiley I spoke with
her day before yesterday she is closing
the Gap we're sending more resources her
way because we know that the Red Wave is
coming but it doesn't have an all by
itself we have to make sure from sea to
shining sea we show up get our voters
out and make sure that you call your
friends if you don't have one Lindsey
Graham says make one today we need every
single voter showing up showing out and
we will have a majority in the Senate
we'll have a 25-seat majority in the
house and we will restore sanity to the
greatest nation on God's green earth
let's give you if if Republicans win
Senator you have been one of the most
powerful advocates for so many people a
big part of their success will be
because of your hard work and efforts
traveling around the country Senator Tim
Scott we always appreciate you being on
thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else